[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el domingo
chile logró instalar la convención
compuesta por 155 representantes que
redactarán una nueva constitución en un
plazo máximo de un año para sustituir a
la carta magna heredada de la dictadura
de augusto pinochet para hablar de lo
que esto significa nos acompaña a
gabriel gaspar el cientista político
analista y ex diplomático chileno
gracias a ustedes por estar con nosotros
en france 24 y comenzamos hablando de la
que ha sido la noticia protagonista en
las últimas horas la doctora y académica
indígena mapuche elisa loncón yo fue
elegida como presidenta de la convención
un órgano paritario compuesto por 77
mujeres y 78 hombres con una cuota
especial para las comunidades indígenas
en su discurso sus primeras palabras
fueron en lengua
madhu punto un boom que supone que una
mujer indígena presida este órgano
constituyente y qué importancia ha
tenido en los movimientos feministas de
chilenos en esta elección
bueno muy buenos días nuestro saludo a
los del santiago de chile es una de la
alegría para todos los chilenos el
inicio de este proceso porque ya la
primera vez que el país
construye una constitución con la
participación soberana de toda la
ciudadanía anteriormente todas las
constituciones fueron redactadas por
decirlo así equipos de notables y lo que
señalas de la designación de la doctora
elisa loncón es una señal potente del
nuevo chile que amanece porque
representa el primero al un
reconocimiento a los pueblos originarios
de los cuales
no soy neutral culo soy bien aymara y da
mucho gusto que una hermana con nosotros
sea la importante tarea segunda de
regiones de la araucanía el tercero no
digo en oro de importancia es mujer
entre esa diversidad expresa digamos la
pluralidad que hoy día representa el
chile y todos esperamos y haremos los
votos porque este proceso culmine con
una nueva institucionalidad que permita
ser también un camino de salida a la
actual crisis que vivió el país en el
último tiempo y quiere que hablemos de
eso que pasará durante los próximos
meses y cuáles son los desafíos a los
que se enfrentan los miembros de la
sociedad civil encargados de redactar
esta nueva constitución
bueno vamos a tener dos procesos
políticos paralelos y sería bueno
precisar lo en primer lugar a este que
señalamos que es el constituyente que es
un proceso de redacción porque vemos los
y del nuevo pacto social de chip
en el cual ayunas está expresada la
diversidad chilena
existen bancadas de todo tiempo por
llamarlo de alguna manera emerge una
nueva generación de líderes políticos y
sociales del país y está en proceso de
proceso constituyente pero al panel leal
paralelo tenemos otro proceso que es la
elección de presidentes y parlamentarios
en el margen de la actual constitución
de la que dejará de regir en un año y
ese proceso electoral se desarrollará en
noviembre de este año por tanto a ese
nuevo gobierno le corresponderá
implementar las directrices y las normas
que surjan de la nueva constitución
desafío pueblo que tiene chile que son
muy parecido a los de américa latina es
pandemia en lo inmediato recesión
económica
paralelo y un acumulado de injusticia y
desigualdad
lo último bueno y ya para decirle cuáles
eran estos asuntos centrales que se
discutirán en los próximos meses
en la constituyente bueno son los
básicos el primero cuáles son los
derechos los principales derechos en el
que el estado tiene que cautelar para
todos los chilenos desde los derechos
sociales hasta la igualdad y la equidad
entre por ahora los sectores del país el
segundo una novela fue una forma de
gobierno que evite crisis como las que
hemos tenido por ejemplo de un
presidencialismo que es muy poco
flexible y que da la situación de que
desde una autoría tiene un 6 por ciento
7 por ciento de aprobación ciudadana sin
embargo sigue gobernando y no solamente
su mandato a un referéndum
aprobación también es obviamente el
carácter plurinacional que yo creo que
comunitario
en la mayoría de los constituyentes
reconocer y por lo mismo
saldar la deuda histórica del estado
pues muchísimas gracias a ustedes
gabriel gaspar analista y ex
bibliográfico chileno para hablar de la
construcción de la nueva constitución de
chile siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]